all right
hi everyone uh welcome this uh session
is called easier infrastructure and
safer secrets and in this session we're
going to be using
a tool called palumi the azure cloud and
a little bit of
net core to demonstrate how we can
spin up infrastructure in a way that's
pretty easy uh but also in a way that's
safe
and a way that helps everybody
not make giant mistakes so
who am i my name's ryan uh
i like to play guitar i like to travel a
bit when it's not 2020
and i like to barbecue things i've got
some my contact details down here on the
bottom if
you're interested in reaching out to me
i'll show these again at the end
and in my professional role at the
moment i'm the cto at
a startup called amphora data so we
operate a real-time data marketplace
and we also build uh intelligent
applications
um currently we are part of the unsw 10x
founder program uh we've actually got
some pretty
cool uh announcements to make in about
two weeks time so
keep an eye on that uh if you're
interested and again feel free to reach
out if
if anything in here distracts you as
interest
so what are we going to talk about so
firstly we're going to talk about
uh what is infrastructure automation and
how to do with bulimi
and i'll run through a demo of of
bulimia sort of halfway through this
uh this presentation um then we're going
to talk about secrets secrets management
and some methods you can use
to manage your secrets we'll briefly
touch on some parts of asp.net core
which are really useful if you're um
using a lot of secrets and and you want
to write nice looking code that's easy
and then at the end if we have time i'll
show you how you can do
mostly secret list deployments and for
that we'll use
polymer gain and github actions
so infrastructure automation i think a
lot of us here have probably
done quite a lot of infrastructure
automation
but when we do it we to my mind want at
least these three
desirable properties for whatever tool
we're using
and there might be some arguments here
and maybe there's a fourth maybe
maybe there's some other ones but this
is just my opinion
but the three i think are really
important uh repeatability
a property called adam potency and
another one called
understandability repeatability is is
pretty clear what it means it means
i can do the same thing more than once
and if i do it in different places the
same thing happens
that's really a property we want on most
of our tooling
understandability means that i know
by looking at this code what it does and
i know how to change it
again like we want that in most of our
tooling right
the third one item potency is a little
bit more subtle
and i'll talk about that in a moment but
basically what it means is that when i
do something multiple times
it has no extra side effects from doing
multiple doing something more than once
so firstly let's look at repeatability
generally speaking you know in a first
forays into cloud infrastructure when we
first
start getting into it we're going to go
to you know a web interface like the aws
portal
uh sorry the aws console or the azure
portal and we're going to play around
with that we're going to create some
virtual machines or some
s3 buckets or something like that once
we're comfortable
with that we start scripting right we
start automating and we do that because
we're software engineers and we love
automating things
a common place to start is just to start
writing bash scripts and you know this
is
how i started automating infrastructure
and i've just got a little sample here
on how you can
do some basic automation and in this
sample i've just got a bash script that
uses the
azure cli cross platform tool to create
a resource group a dns zone and an a
record
in that dns zone right pretty basic
cloud infrastructure kind of stuff
but what happens if i run this thing
more than once
and what happens is that i get an error
okay
and the error says i'm not allowed to
create
more than one record of type a with the
same ip address
that makes a lot of sense right because
in regular dns things you can't
have uh more than one a record with the
same ip address
but if you think about it why did it
fail at that point
if i go back to the script i also can't
have
multiple resource groups of the same
name
but it didn't fail there i also can't
have multiple
dns zones with the same name but it also
didn't fail there it failed on the third
one
and the reason it did that is because
the first two operations were item
potent but the third one was not
and this is a problem
so what is item potency item potency
means that
when we apply an operation once or apply
it multiple times
it has the same effect
often this is just called like a desired
state model
and you've probably seen this in your
day-to-day lives
when you multiply by zero that's an
idempotent operation
because multiplying by zero once or a
thousand times
doesn't change the answer it's still
zero
we see technologies like this every day
something like an elevated call button
or a pedestrian crossing where pressing
the button
more than once doesn't make a difference
contrary to what i believed as a child
and if anyone's used kubernetes
the kubernetes api and kubernetes
controllers are another example
of an item potent system where
the command you know cube control apply
applying it once
or applying it 10 times doesn't make a
difference
hopefully
and look the third the third property
that's really important when we're
looking at
infrastructure automation uh is
understandability
right and a great way to do this is just
to use familiar languages
right you can
write something in javascript and most
people are going to be able to read it
and understand it and if it's not
javascript then it's maybe python or
c-sharp
or go i bet 95 percent
of people uh in this
virtual room could read or write at
least one of these
languages i have on screen now
you could probably write this yourself
you know you could probably
write your own infrastructure automation
tool in in python that
you know checked if an ip address
uh already existed in a dns zone
and and only created it if it didn't
exist
but why would you bother when there's
already
a free tool that does it for you
and you probably guessed that tool is
called polyme
so in a way polomi is very similar to
terraform
and if anyone out there has used
terraform then
these concepts which i'm going to talk
about next are going to feel really
similar
so you know why do i like plumi well of
course it
meets the criteria that i just set
pollumi is understandable
because when we read it it's written
in programming languages uh that we
usually can understand like python
javascript or go
it has this property of repeatability
via these concepts of projects and
stacks
and i'll go into that in a moment on how
they work
and it achieves item potency in the same
way that terraform does
via a desired state configuration
methodology
there's some other cool reasons why you
might like plummy so it's all open
source
the whole thing's on on github it's got
a consistent programming model if you're
programming across multiple clouds say
gcp and aws not that i necessarily
recommend doing that but if that's what
you're doing then
they look the same then doesn't matter
where you're deploying to
uh it enables testing of infrastructure
which can be quite cool especially
because you can
actually write unit tests on your
infrastructure code if you want to
and it does have a policy as
code engine that to be honest i'm not uh
very familiar with but i think if you
are you know programming infrastructure
in large enterprise
environments and large enterprise
companies then policy
and compliance become really important
so what are the pollumi concepts that
you need to know if you
really want to go deep and become a
wizard
at using it so obviously it's a cli i'll
briefly talk about that
there's three concepts which are the
program the project and the stack
which are kind of the core of what plume
is and how it works
and then we'll also talk about how to
configure it
and what the state means in pollumi
so the main way you'll interact with
bulumi is via a command line interface
a cli and you can install this on on
whatever os you're using it runs on
you know linux mac os and windows
and if you look at the help function
you'll see
there's some common commands that it
suggests
you'll use most of the time the most
common command
is just called pulling me up and what
that does is it spins up your
infrastructure
as you've defined it in code the other
commands that it recommends you
understand are plummy stack
which is the cli way you interact with
instances
of your infrastructure you can configure
it via the cli
and you can also destroy your
infrastructure via the cli and this is
really useful when you have modular
components
which i just want to create and destroy
as i like
so what's a polymer project really it's
just
any directory which contains a
polymer.yaml file
and there's not too much yamlin plumi so
you don't get into
yaml hell but anyway where you see this
kind of a file where it's got a name
a particular runtime which is the
language we get to write our
infrastructure code in and a little
description which will show up you know
when you look at the web interface and
so it gives people a little idea of
what the point of the infrastructure is
and this
uh if you want to compare it to
terraform is similar to the root module
which is kind of the only required
module when you're when you're working
in terraform
the next thing that's important to
understand is the plumi program
so in pollumi a program
is literally the way you define
your infrastructure and you can write it
in in any of the supported languages
which there's five and although you are
using a general purpose language
the magic of bulimia is it turns that
into a desired state it turns it into a
declarative
piece of infrastructure rather than the
normal method of programming you would
you would normally be familiar with
so in this example this is a python
example
and we're using python to create this
group object
and this server object now the group
object
maps to an aws ec2 security group and
we've got some properties that we put on
there like the description and
you know the protocol it supports and
the port and et cetera
and then we also create an ec2 instance
where we
you know give it an instance type and
and we pass in the security group that
it's a part of
now the way that polymer works
these objects that you create in python
which is obviously an object-oriented
language mostly
they map pretty much one to one with the
cloud resources that end up getting
created
so when i instantiate an object in
pollumi
that maps to a cloud provider or any
kind of provider creating some cloud
resource for us
these objects these cloud resources
these polymer resources
they're hierarchically organized and you
can have
many children of these objects but the
root object
is the stack
so a paloomy stack is comparable
in terraform land to a terraform
workspace
so every polymery program must be
deployed to a stack
there's no way around it and a stack
is an isolated and independently
configurable instance
of your program the main
reason you would have more than one
stack is because you might have a
production stack so your production set
of infrastructure
and a development and test set of that
infrastructure
and what you want and this is a part of
the repeatability property that we were
looking for
is for those stacks
those bits of infrastructure to be
similar
in that i want my development
environment to be like my production
environment
i don't want them to drift otherwise how
can i be sure that when i do something
in develop
it's gonna work the same in production
but we can have differences between our
stacks you know i don't necessarily want
a monster virtual machine in my
development environment i kind of don't
care
about latency and there's probably not
much load on my development environment
so
what we can do by the pollumi
configuration
tool is to make sure our stacks
have different values inside them so
really common example is going to be
making sure your development environment
has a smaller type of virtual machine
or maybe a smaller number of virtual
machines than your production
environment
so the last concept uh you should
understand
when you're working with palumi uh is
the polymer state
now this is very similar to the
terraform state
basically it's a snapshot of your
infrastructure
at any time and that state
changes as you run pulling me up
or you edit the state manually and
pulling me uses that state
to basically do a diff between what you
want
your infrastructure to look like and
what it
looks like right now
so this is like an overview of how that
happens right
so when i write a pollumi program let's
say i write it in javascript
that file runs inside the pollumi
language host
as the javascript file runs
the pollumi it's almost like a run time
captures
the objects that were created or watches
the objects that were created
and uses that to create the new state
of our infrastructure it then in the
engine
compares that new state to the current
state and decides
what changes it needs to make to ensure
that
the deployed state becomes like our
desired state
and it does this by the three operations
create update and delete
and it can do that on any
uh provider that you can plug in to
plummy so there's actually a lot of
providers
you know there's a gcp provider as well
as the ones i've sort of listed up here
but you know so
i can create something in aws i can
update something in azure and i can
delete something in kubernetes
so enough theory let's
see if we can just do a demo where's on
my
there it is
okay so
what i'm gonna do whoops
is i'm going to show you how you can
actually get started
with polyme so i'm going to
just create a new directory just to put
it somewhere
let's call it ndc
and i'm going to show you the kinds of
options you have when you
are creating a new pollumi program i do
that by the plume and new command
and you can see pretty quickly that
there's a lot of options
i can code stuff for aws for azure for
gcp
for kubernetes and i can
do it in these five languages c sharp go
javascript
or typescript what i'm going to do
is i'm going to create a new azure
typescript
gloomy program and it's going to prompt
me
to give me some information so it knows
how to spin up this
or how to template this code for me so
i'm just going to call this project
the plumi project like we were
discussing ndc the default
again just this default project
description
now we get to pick a stack and
you could name the stack whatever you
want uh you might you know name it
your name if you want different stacks
for the different developers but again
i'm just going to keep it as the default
the dev stack
we can choose the azure environment even
but of course i'm just going to pick
public
and lastly we can choose the default
azure location because this technically
is ndc sydney
even though i'm in melbourne i'm going
to pick australia east
all right and now that's gonna go and
create
uh the project and right now it's
actually doing
an npm install and the reason it's doing
that is because we created a typescript
program
and the next thing it does is it
downloads the
that we need to use remember how
pollumi can work with many clouds and
many providers
this plugin lets follow me with azure
cool we're up and ready to go so let's
have a look at what this
code actually looks like
um i'm not gonna full screen like that
do it like this
i'll zoom in so everyone can see that
okay so i can tell i'm in a pollumi
program because
i've got my plumie.yaml here but the
real
meat of the mata happens here
in index.ts
so in index.ts is where we're actually
going to define
our infrastructure so i can see
just by reading this this is a property
of understandability
what this program is going to do and
pretty obvious it's going to create a
resource group and then it's going to
create a storage account
by newing up these objects
and down the bottom here it's going to
export the connection string
for the storage account
okay so let's do that
i've got a short alias for gloomy
just p in my shell but this is just
equivalent to writing poly me up
and now this is going to go and compare
the desired state that it gets from
running
that program with the actual state
and of course the actual state is empty
because we only just created this stack
and it tells me what it's going to do
right it knows that it's got to create a
resource group and it knows it's got to
create a storage account
so let's do that
and now you can watch these things being
created one thing you'll notice
is that i didn't have to give
a lot of res a lot of parameters to the
creation of this resource group
if i mouse over this you'll see from the
intellisense that there are a bunch of
options i could pass into this
constructor
but the only one i need to pass is this
name
at least for the azure resource group
type that name is actually not the name
of the
resource group in azure it's actually
the name
of the resource in pollumi
you look at this name here
name resource group that's the name we
defined
the actual resource group that got
created is not going to be called
resource group it's going to have a kind
of
random name basically and i can probably
show you that
i refresh that
oh
god that one but not that one
interesting
um don't know where that went obviously
not that subscription
um okay but what i'm going to show you
is now how when you make a change the
way pollumi plans
and knows how to make changes
so you can pass options into your
resource group
and enforce it to do different behavior
so one of the options i
you can pass is for example the name
okay and i'm just going to call this you
know ndc
demo my resource group now this is the
name of the resource group
that i've forced to be this property and
now if i
flew me up again
it's going to do the same thing it did
before compare the current state to my
desired state
and then it's going to tell me via this
preview feature what it has to do
and you'll see that it knows
that the resource group's name has
changed from this diff here
and it also knows that resource groups
in azure can't have their names changed
resource groups are kind of stuck with
the name that they're created with
so when i go to change the name it knows
that this is a destructive process
for this resource group and it needs to
be deleted
and then replaced it also knows
because of the dependency tree which it
infers from this line
that the resource group for our storage
account
uh is the resource group that we created
above that the storage account
also needs to be deleted and recreated
and then it also has inferred that the
connection string output
which you see here is going to be
deleted and it's going to be
recreated with a with a new
connection string the way polyme deals
with this
dependency or unknown at plan time value
is it uses this type called output so
this is a string
but before the storage account is
created we don't know what the
connection string is going to be so we
use this placeholder called the output
so i'm not going to do that what i'm
actually going to do instead is a
destroy
destroyers are really useful because you
don't want lots of infrastructure just
sitting around everywhere it does cost
money i'm sure all of us have
experienced cloud bill shock
so what i'm going to do and says i'm
just going to delete this infrastructure
and in a moment i'm going to show you a
more full example
of the kind infrastructure you might
actually want to create that's a bit
more complex than just
a resource group with a storage account
inside it but before we do that
let's talk about secrets
okay so what are secrets
secrets are the things that let you
interact with your infrastructure
right and the hard part about them is
that
they have to go somewhere people need
access to them but not everybody
they need to be in the right place at
the right time so you know you're going
to need secrets on your developer
machine
when you want to prototype some new
thing with some new cloud service
you'll need the connection string to
that cloud resource
you'll need secrets in each of your
environments in your development your
staging and your production environment
but you've got to make sure they're
different obviously and you really want
to make sure that your
production secret doesn't end up in your
development environment
it's really painful when you
accidentally run a test
against your production database and
fill it up with something
unpleasant uh and the last place you're
gonna need your secrets are during
integration tests
so how do you make sure that they get
where they to go
diagrammatically we can think about it
like this you know we've got secrets
that get generated
in a bunch of places maybe they're you
know existing
third parties that we've we're using you
know so maybe
we're using sendgrid and we've got an
api key that we need
obviously you've got your cloud
credentials which are really important
and you've also got secrets for the
things that you create in the cloud
so when i create a database i get a
connection string
when i create a container registry um
i get an admin password and a login
url and i already mentioned the kind of
places that we need
these things so what we really need in
this situation
is an abstraction layer that
solves these problems but in each of
these
places it just feels like we're
consuming a secret that
you know we didn't even care where it
came from we just know that it works
which came first the chicken or the
secret no matter how
hard you try you can't get rid of
secrets altogether
you can imagine putting all of your
secrets in a box
and then lock the box with a key but now
this key is just
the uber secret right so but there is a
useful
concept here which is useful and that's
the concept of identity
all of the big cloud providers have this
concept of identity uh
and basically an identity is not
attached to
just a single secret that gives you
access
it groups secrets together and those
secrets have roles and capabilities
so just as an example i have an identity
uh in azure active directory
and that identity lets me interact with
some azure subscriptions
but not others so identity is a good
place to have the root secret
for your infrastructure
so for the infrastructure that i've been
creating my password essentially for my
azure active directory account is the
root secret
so what are some of the tools that we
can use
to enable this abstraction so
all of the three big cloud providers
have their own
uh built-in product for this
that does this kind of role in azure
it's called key vault in aws it's called
secrets manager
and gcp it's this kms thing and there's
also a tool i want to mention here
called hashicorp vault
which is different from the others in
that it's actually a binary that you can
deploy anywhere
and so again this one's going to be
really useful if you're doing
cross cloud stuff where you need to
manage your secrets in one location
so of course you know they all support
rotation which is pretty basic
they all have a pollumi provider which
is really useful so you can create these
things or manage them in pollumi
if you're using asp.net which i have
been using
heavily there is a slight advantage
that azure and aws have over the others
which is uh
they have an asp.net configuration
integration
now this is just a new nuget package so
it's nothing fundamental about those
products and
and actually if you know of an asp.net
configuration
sdk for gcp or hashicorp um i'd love to
know about it
premier prove this slide wrong um but
that's
really the only reason why you would
choose one over the other and of course
the main reason is you know if you're
purely on aws
then just use aws sequence manager you
don't need to go
and use anything else just use the
default
okay so i'm going to give you a very
brief uh introduction to asp.net core
just so you understand what we're
talking about
so blah blah blah this is what it says
on the
you know website if you go to asp.net
core website but all you really need to
know is look it's a
modern web server written in c sharp and
you get to write c
sharp that's it
one thing it does use very heavily is
dependency injection
and dependency injection is probably the
most useful
concept and pattern i think i ever
learned
in in my career so you know a dependency
is obviously an object that another
object
depends on and the benefits of
dependency injection
is that your implementation is
abstracted away from where it's used so
i
as the consumer i don't need to care how
it's implemented
those implementations can then be
replaced so
i can connect to either
azure sql database or a document db
database and
as long as i'm using some kind of
interface
then i don't necessarily care what the
underlying database
technology is it also means that your
instantiation of these kind of objects
can be centralized
which is useful when you want to control
the amount of connections that you might
be making to a database for example you
don't want to make
10 000 connections because you'll
exhaust the pool pretty quickly
uh and the kind of last really useful
thing
that dependency injection means is that
we can
mock some dependencies during during
testing and the ultimate result of all
this
is that you get loosely coupled software
and in this instance
what we care about when we talk about
infrastructure and secrets is we want to
loosely couple our software
from where the secrets come from
so the way you do that if you're using
asp.net is you use
the configuration system so what that
does it
injects your configurations including
your secrets at runtime
and the secret provider is abstracted
from the consumer
i've got a short example piece of code
just to give you a
sense of what this looks like in this
class you know we've got a constructor
that uses the i options monitor
interface which is a generic
for this my options
class and then when the method my method
is called
the current value of
that options is now read into this
variable
and what's useful is that this option
could be set anywhere
this option could be set in a json file
it could be set in an environment
variable
it could be a secret stored in azure key
vault
but when i'm writing this code i don't
need to worry about where it came from
so that's the end of the
theory section of this presentation what
i'm going to do now is i'm going to show
you a
demonstration repository and code
that does a lot of this stuff and what
it's going to do is
it's going to take some secrets that get
generated
in pollumi it's going to store those
secrets in key vault
and then it's going to allow
certain identities but not in others to
access that keyboard
read the secret and then consume it
so this is all um
on this repository which i can provide a
link to this
uh in the slack channel um at the end of
this
talk so you guys can see what i'm
talking about
but i think it's probably easier just to
show you what it looks like
very zoomed in
okay so in this repository we've got
our source code and inside our source
code we've got two directories we've got
our infrastructure directory
and our app directory now
our app directory is pretty close to
a file new project asp.net
application um it's an asp.net
application
using react um so that's why we've got
this client app thing and
you know i can dig into client app and i
can see what it is but
the kind of main interesting point of
this
asp.net application is in the program
and the startup
so for those of you familiar with
asp.net
you'll recognize this kind of
entry point and what we've done
at this entry point is we've
added this use key vault
and this used keyboard method is what
connects our key vault
into our configuration system
so what we've done is we've grabbed the
keyboard uri
from our settings and so this is
actually going to come
through the environment variable and
then
using the azure service token provider
and the key vault client
we connect it all up and this is all
done in the nougat package you don't
need to worry too much about this
and the long story short is that you get
your secrets now injected
into your configuration system i'm not
going to go too deeply into this
code you can see this on github
and you can poke around with it but all
you need to know really is that
this nougat package means that your
secrets end up where they need to be
the one kind of interesting part here is
i think this azure service token
provider
what that does is it looks for an
identity that's
going to be attached to the
to wherever this application is running
and it's going to grab a token
related to that identity and then that's
the token that's going to use
to access the key vault and i think a
good way to
demonstrate how that works is to show uh
what that looks like in the plumi
program
so i've put everything into one big
file called index.ts but you don't need
to do that
because this is just a regular
typescript program you can
break this up into multiple files you
can
create your own custom resources if you
want to do that
you can do most of the things you can do
in in javascript
so i've got this section here between
lines 11 and 17
that's really meant to show why you
might use pollumi
rather than something like terraform
and this is kind of a silly example
where we're going to check if it's a
friday and
you know if it is a friday so the day of
week is five
then we're just gonna throw we're gonna
say you know hey don't deploy on friday
that's a that's a big mistake
and the reason i'm doing this is to show
you that
when you're writing programs in pollumi
you still get all of the
nice magic that you get from writing
regular javascript
doing this kind of a comparison this
kind of control flow
would be quite difficult in terraform
because you don't get
you know methods like this and you don't
get to
write you know easy to read if
statements
so let me kind of scroll through this
and
i'll show you what we're doing here
this is kind of a little bit too long
for me really to
go into all of it in depth so
if there's any questions you can type in
the chat and i can
address them but similar to before you
know we're going to create a resource
group
this time i'm going to give it some tags
and a name
um i'm going to create a key vault right
again i'm just going to give it the
regular sku and i also have to give it
the tenant id
which is something specific to the key
vault
object similar as to before i'm going to
create a storage account
and i can do quite complex stuff right i
can create a storage container in the
storage account i can create a storage
account
table you can get quite granular
with what you're doing and you can even
if you want to import
the azure storage sdk and start to
manipulate things
inside the table if you really want to
because it's good practice i'm going to
create an app insights application
insights monitoring thing
i'm going to create a container registry
because
one of the things i'm going to do is i'm
going to build a docker image of my
asp.net
application and i'm going to push it to
this container registry
and i can do that using this polyme tool
or this sort of not tool
class called a docker image
and i give it the context which is app
which i was just showing you and i give
it the registry
that we want to push to and
when i run this it's going to go in and
push this
image up to my registry
last couple of things we want to do is
obviously we want to run this
application somewhere and i'm going to
run it in an app service plan
and because i want to use containers i
want to run it that way then i'm going
to have to create a linux container
uh and i have to give it this screw
there's a bunch of options you can give
it here
and then within the app service we
created we actually have to create
an app service plan sorry we actually
have to create an application
and we can do stuff like set settings
the app settings
and this is also a piece of
configuration
so there is at least one secret
that we'll need to actually no there's
no secrets here look at that
magic oh okay so there's the
applications instrumentation key
kind of a secret but mostly not but we
do need to say
where it's going to pull the container
from
the kind of secret or the kind of key
we're going to give it is this
identity object and this is like a
managed identity in azure
and it's going to use this identity to
access the key vault and then get all
the other secrets that it's going to
need
but we do need to say it is allowed
access to keyboard
and we do that by creating key vault
access policies
i looped through all of the access
policies some are static and some aren't
but the one you probably care about
is the one for the application
do you like keeping yourself on your
mute sorry if you're
cool uh and then okay once we've created
all this infrastructure all we need to
do now is store
the secrets that we need to use in our
um in our key vault
so i grab the connection string
from my storage account and i can store
it in the key vault using this
azure keyboard secret class
but to make it really obvious what's
happening i
can also just store arbitrary strings
and i'm
going to store this string here for you
so
let's say hello
and dc sydney
save that
and
[Music]
there we go
i'm in the trash
i can use this command to check which
stack i'm a part of i want to be in this
dev stack because we also have a
production stack which i'll show you in
a moment
and i'm just going to spin up my
infrastructure
so what you'll see here is you'll see
it'll plan the kinds of changes it needs
to make because there are no resources
it's going to have to create everything
and all of these
pollumi resources map exactly to the
code that we just saw
so you can see the docker image that i
defined you can see the resource group
you can see the storage accounts plus
the container and table
you can even see the access policies so
everything that is getting created
every every object that i created in my
pollute program
is now being turned into literally
resources in azure
and what's really interesting i think is
that you can do stuff that is not
related to
just azure so like i said i'm creating a
docker image here
you can even see some of the some of the
docker commands kind of
popping up in the blog here on the right
now you don't have to do it this way you
can also create your infrastructure and
then deploy your containers in a
different way
and there are pros and cons one way or
the other
this way is is simpler in the sense that
i just have to
run polyme up and everything gets spun
up for me i don't have to run a second
process
but the downside here is you don't get
to do any kind of promoting
you know you can't do blue green
deployments very easily this way
you can't use the the promotion feature
in app service for example
app service has a way of setting slots
and then promoting
from that slot up into production
and back again
so you can see most of these things are
created except for the key vault
and then it actually even pushed
my image up to the
container registry and while this is
ready to finish look let me show you
what
the
oh let me show you how you can actually
put this into production
so you can see from this that as long as
we can run plummy up
with an identity that has access to our
azure subscription then we can create
the infrastructure that we care about
you can also see that i've got two
stacks
one of them is my oops
my development stack and one of them is
my production stack
in development i can you know change the
configuration if i want to
and in production i've actually got a
slightly different configuration
in production i'm i've added this
service principle to the kind of
identities that i want to have access to
the keyboard
and that's because in production this
service principle
is going to be running on my github
actions host and that's where we want to
run our
integration tests and that's why this
service principle will need access to
the keyboard
so when i deploy this via github actions
and i'll show you
apologies for so much yaml
uh you can you can basically grab yaml
very similar to this
uh drop it in your repository under
github workflows
and then when you start pushing code
it's going to
spin it up for you you can do it after
you run tests
you can target different environments
so it's pretty simple i just basically
install
polomi i run plumey up
and i give it the secrets that it needs
to run
so the kind of secrets it needs
obviously needs access to azure which
are these first three
and it also needs access to your pollumi
account so
i sort of glossed over earlier how you
can install and initialize polyme on
your machine
it's relatively simple it's quite
similar to how you would log into the
azure cli
uh you can just log in by the cli and
it'll take you to a browser and
and do a redirect um i know idc redirect
for you
so coming back to our plume up
that was running here my dev machine
you can see this has all been created
and i've got
an endpoint and this endpoint is my
azure websites
app service url and if i go to it
okay cool i can see my program is
running
it looks like it's working and i've
put a little dodgy bit here where in
this
basic weather component um page
which comes out of the box when you do a
um
create a new project an asp.net project
i've just
tacked the secret onto the end there and
you can see the secret says
hello ndc sydney which is
the same secret i set
in index hello ndc sydney
now one thing to be aware of is that
often these secrets are cached so
if i change this to hello melbourne
and run the same thing again it is going
to detect that there are changes
and it actually is going to change the
um secret in key vault
the challenge becomes the application
caches these secrets
it catches all of its configuration and
that's a good thing because you don't
want your application going back to key
vault
every single time it needs the
connection string
for example but on the other hand what
it means is that
when i change the secret like i just did
and i come and refresh this page it
still says
hello ndc sydney and that's because it's
cached
so there's two ways you can
solve this problem one is you can call a
method
called configuration.reload inside
your application but how are you going
to know to do that it's a bit
complicated
i find the easiest way is just to force
restarts of your application now and
then
so i mean if i deploy a new container if
i make changes to the container and i
deploy it then it's going to
force a restart and it's going to reload
all of my secrets
and it's probably going to just
naturally cycle at some point when the
underlying infrastructure changes
one thing you may want to see as well is
what this looks like uh when i deploy
via
actions so that yaml i showed you
earlier
that defines this github
workflow that runs
uh you can see it all of these runs here
you can see all the times i
broke it and it didn't work
and you can even see where i ran blew me
up
and i did all of the stuff that you saw
running on my machine it built the
container
created all of the things and etc
and you can even see here the endpoint
for my production thing a different
endpoint
different secret and if i go here
you'll see a different secret to the one
i said in my development environment
so this is really important make sure
that
when you're deploying your things and
you're using your secrets
you can ensure that your secrets uh
in your development environment your
production environment are different
uh last thing i will show you uh
is what pollumi looks like in the
web uh in the web interface
i can see i need to refresh that
somewhere here i'm going to have my ndc
stack
and this is a useful way to keep an eye
on what's going on
in your infrastructure it's kind of like
a different view so here i can see
my um ndc project sorry and i can see
uh the stuff i've been doing recently i
can see you know
in the master environments i
run this before oh this is actually the
one i created as a demo
earlier that's not what i wanted to show
you
it's actually this one
this is one we were just looking at and
i can see the same endpoint
the same keyboard url the name of the
resource group
and i can even dive in and start to look
at some of the resources inside
so for example i can look at the docker
image and i can see you know exactly the
docker image that's deployed i can see
the logs that were associated with it
so this is quite a useful way to get
insight into what's going on
uh in your infrastructure how it's
getting deployed
and i tend to use this if i don't
understand
a problem that's that's occurred or
something like that
okay so pretty much run out of time
and i know that was a big demo but what
i wanted to show you
is how you can do this
without exposing a lot of secrets like
you notice i did that whole thing
without
exposing any connection strings or
anything on
on the um on this recording
so a short number of sort of tips and
takeaways
things that i've learned from doing a
lot of pulling me ups
first one is you know smaller stacks and
more of them
one giant stack becomes quite complex
pollumi destroy can be a lot trickier
than pulling me up
because when the infrastructure gets
destroyed it
destroys it in reverse order of
dependency
and if there's one thing that can't be
destroyed
then anything that came before it
in the dependency tree also won't be
destroyed and so
you can kind of get stuck because one
thing can't be deleted
one way to sometimes get around that is
using a
command called polymer refresh and that
can fix some problems but it can also
cause others what polymer refresh does
is it
looks at your cloud infrastructure
compares it to your current state
and then will if you want it to
update your current state to attempt to
reflect the actual infrastructure so
a good example of that might be in some
of those previous examples if i had used
the azure portal to delete the
storage account then
when i run plume refresh the
state of my plumi stack will be updated
to reflect the fact that that storage
account had been deleted
so also use dependency injection it's
really great i saw another talk this
morning recommending dependency
injection
similarly use configuration and
when you can prefer identity to a secret
so if you can access a database or a
container registry
or a key vault or whatever
via some kind of identity method rather
than just a
straight up connection string or a
straight up secret then you should
always prefer that method
because it's easier and you're less
likely to expose a secret either in a
git repository or when you're sharing
your screen
so thanks for coming and learning about
how to create infrastructure and how to
protect your secrets
uh i do have the slack channel open if
anyone has any questions but
i also know it's 12 30 and right before
lunch
so happy today questions um and if
you don't want to ask here you can
always reach out to me by any of these
contact methods i've listed below
thanks everyone
you